[Music]
is still on trial for corruption and
fraud and yet he is on course to win
another election and so complete an
extraordinary return to power
Netanyahu will move back into the prime
minister's residence in Jerusalem for a
sixth time he only left it 16 months ago
another story has emerged from this
election the rise of a far-right
nationalist itamar bengavir
three weeks ago in the Arab District of
Chicago in East Jerusalem he pulled out
a gun and was heard urging police to
fire on Palestinians
the price of his support in a coalition
might Force Netanyahu to appoint him
policing minister
benevier keeps a temporary office in
sheikhjara it incites regular protests
that often turn very violent next door
only yards away is nazira
she's a widow with four children and has
lived in her house for 60 years she
tells us she is scared about what will
happen next
every night is ready settlers disturb
her and she thinks she will now be
evicted from her house within the year
violence in the West Bank is increasing
this happened today
a car rammed into a checkpoint and the
driver a Palestinian was shot dead and
Israeli was badly wounded
the worsening security situation
influenced many voters
yeah very good why and there's more
treatments
why uh strong right safety good
and security security yeah negotiations
to form a governing Coalition might take
weeks the horse trading is often messy
and unpredictable
but this election has pushed Israeli
politics to the far right the divisions
are widening
Aleister bunkel Sky News in Jerusalem